momento de actualizar la información
económica en france 24 y por ello le doy
la bienvenida de compañero luís méndez
luis iniciamos con una nota sobre el
crecimiento de américa latina para el
próximo año que en el marco de la
vigésimo quinta edición de la
conferencia anual del banco de
desarrollo para américa latina la
titular de la cepal alicia bárcena
advirtió sobre el retorno de una senda
de bajo crecimiento para la región en su
intervención bárcena resaltó que
latinoamérica fue una de las regiones
más impactadas por la pandemia con una
contracción de 6.8 por ciento y se
espera un crecimiento de 59 por ciento
para este año que considera insuficiente
para la recuperación entre los elementos
que podrían generar la ralentización
económica en américa latina' para el año
2022 está la asimetría en los procesos
de vacunación pero escuchamos que otras
afirmaciones destacó durante su
intervención
este crecimiento es el reflejo de un
rebote estadístico muy influido por el
consumo porque la mayoría de los países
aplicaron medidas de apoyo a los hogares
a la demanda griega y esto ayudó pues al
consumo privado pero no es crecimiento
genuino también hay una cierta dinámica
preocupante porque volvemos a la
reprimarización de las economías porque
hay mejores precios de los commodities
en realidad es que el 2022 va a haber
una ralentización vamos ir nuevamente
haga a estas digamos niveles de
crecimiento francamente medio les 2,9
calculamos nosotros lo hiciera pasamos a
argentina porque se mantiene el debate
en torno a la medida de precios
congelados que pretende establecer el
gobierno debate que podría tornarse de
polémico para los próximos días porque a
pesar de no haber alcanzado un acuerdo
el gobierno estableció el plan en
1432 productos esto de acuerdo con
medios como ámbitos financieros y clarín
la medida sorprendió a los empresarios y
el anuncio oficial se hará efectivo este
miércoles con la publicación en el
boletín oficial pero previo a esta
decisión la agrupación de productores de
alimentos había reaccionado a través de
un comunicado en el que cuestionó el
congelamiento de precios
por otro lado el indec ubicó la
inflación en argentina en 35 por ciento
para el mes de septiembre louis y ahora
pasamos a eeuu porque sigue la
preocupación en torno a la inflación y
es que de acuerdo con un informe de la
reserva federal de san francisco el plan
de estímulo de yo va a ir en valorado en
1.9 billones de dólares podría estar
presionando el indicador de inflación en
septiembre aumentó 0 4% y
5,4 por ciento en 12 meses a pesar de
ello el informe emitido señala que el
rescate ayuda a estabilizar el mercado
laboral y se espera un aumento del ipc
en 0.3 puntos para este año 0,2 puntos
para 2022 y será imperceptible en el año
louis y seguimos en francia el gobierno
pretende ayudar a los ciudadanos en
medio de un alza en los precios del
combustible así lo dio a conocer la
ministra de transformación energética
del país barbara pompili aunque no
ofreció mayores detalles de la manera en
la que van a establecer las ayudas en
europa los precios del gas natural
petróleo y carbón se han disparado en
francia el precio del diésel alcanzó un
récord de 1 punto ocho dólares por litro
de acuerdo con la agencia noticias afp
el alto valor de los combustibles ha
elevado la demanda de viajes compartidos
louis y china podría diseñar un plan
para frenar los precios del carbón como
es eso esto es de acuerdo con la
publicación china en global times que
fue from definido a los precios como
irracionales la iniciativa se generó de
la comisión nacional de desarrollo y
reforma que indica un divorcio entre los
precios del carbón y los fundamentos de
oferta y demanda con la finalidad de
estabilizar los precios la comisión
sostuvo un encuentro con empresas y
asociaciones para intervenir en los
precios de acuerdo con la ley en chino
una parte de la electricidad se produce
a partir del carbón y los altos precios
en conjunto con la escasez del mineral
han generado problemas en algunas
empresas y se anuncian cambios en el
fondo monetario internacional y es que
kiko pinatte economista jefe del
organismo dejará este para el próximo
año así se desprende de un comunicado
emitido por el fondo monetario
internacional este martes en el que
expresa que copina dejará su actual
función en diciembre de este año y
regresará al departamento de economía de
la universidad de harvard opiná se había
desempeñado como economista jefe del
organismo durante los últimos tres años
y vamos con los indicadores un optimismo
en el mercado de wall street y por ello
cerraron con números positivos a lo
largo de la jornada mientras tanto en
europa hubo cierres mixtos con la caída
en la bolsa de parís un fenómeno que
también fue trasladado las bolsas de
américa latina donde cerraron tema de la
mixta louis muchas gracias por la
información económica es todo por el
momento muchas gracias por acompañarnos
quédense con nosotros
[Música]
a